ana
あの皆さんに
お願いする前にちょっとこちら宮瀬ある学生さんはもちろんその後両親もまだ大稀に
なってない時の話をちょっとさせていただきたいんですけど
しばらくをつけながらます
私はあの日本人ですけど
関東州の
在園というところで
生まれて
それから
あの父の仕事の都合で法廷って方点で15歳まず育ちました
まあいろんな指で a
アウトサイダーだったと思います大連とは彼になりました
変な撮影ですアナところなんですよ
で私たちはあの大連を
が13分ですから日本のことをない1て言ってましたとりわけ
な市ってどこのこと言って乗って聞かれることがありますけど
それで
まあ15歳馬実装はったんですけれども
第一ではなかなかあの
日本文化に時間にあのあいる
機械があんまりないものですから私たちの両親はもうチャンスを
あるをというのが30と
理由もわかんない小学生の私でもついて
歌舞伎だとかノーだとかっていうのに連れてって
あの勉強させてくれました
それであんな付
その頃あの
日本では
日本の
大学ではあの本なの学生は入れてくれませんでした
で今朝のドラマでもやってますけど日本女子たようなことですね
日本女子大東京受精は津田塾っていうのは皆さん年制の専門学校です皆さんじょう学校
でたとそこいらしたと私たちの学校もが市の学校は
250人そっち口180人もその上級学校行ったんです
で
まあ男大学入れてくれないはず東大の穂積重遠さんて民法学者がまあ人口の半分を灘の
に女にもホリスをしようじゃないかといって各大学にどうだどうだとおっしゃってる
ところがどこの大学もイエスとおっしゃらなかったそうですそうですそんな時に明治
大学がいい
8みんな嫌だって言うんだろ私んとこでもやってみようじゃないかといってだけども
いけないその男の学生と一緒に余暇に入れるわけにはいかない
って言ってそこであ明治大学女子部っていう専門学校別に作って
女の子がその
あの
東急女子味日本女子大という専門学校を出てそしてそのメジャーが控除親父に来てそこ
を3年でたら
法学部い男の学生といえてやろう
その法学部入って話は昔高等文官試験って今
越冬上級公務員試験ですかそういうのがあったんですけど大学剥がれないとその試験を
受ける資格がなかったんですねまぁとにかく号不備れてやる
そんなことだったそうです
それは誰しも所ワークを出てからさて上どこ行くかなぁーとか思ってましたら
さのある日ぜひの母が
新聞の切り抜きを見せて
明治大学があのナム学生も言えるようにしたそうよ
そして
あの初めて
ん女の法律がもうできたと弁護士だと母曰く私が考えるにはあの日で目が
女子部へ行って大学行って卒業する頃には
弁グッズだけじゃなくて女の裁判官も女の掲示文できると思うんだけどと言って私は
そそのかしたんです
私は最初は女子戦って者になろうと思ってたんですけどその法律の話を聞きましたら
すごく興味が湧いてじゃあ明治に行かせてよって言って
で目座薬行きたいわけですねですからもう先輩たちは皆さん
あのその専門学校でになってもうすでに
あの社会でて働いてた方が大勢いらっしゃいました私はどういうわけか条学校から来た
んですじゃあこうから
いたのは2人は透けませんですそうですね
まあ
んですけど先輩はもう年が町松私は一番仲良かったかたなぁ彼はあの台湾でしょうが今
先制して明日ってとして中13和会でした
でまぁそんなところでそのお姉さんたちがそのみんなちょっと左かかってるんですね
お姉さんたちがいろんな政治的な話だ仲するにそこへ行って政治幅
入ってますとここでも熱いて寝てのつけて言われて
そんな子そんな時代でした
それ
あの歯麻痺とにかくメジャーが入ったりて学生の頃は
ものすごく真面目に勉強しました
フェイスの1年生の時にとローンカーがあって鶏糞討論会があったんです
議題はねぇ
強盗殺人だったと思いますで丸1年生入ったばかりで警報の総論も終わってないのに
どうやって討論会に出るんだって自分で自分延長しまして
here
が3枚入っていましたそれで先輩たちが見て私の音
判例ばっかり引っ張ってんで判例こじっを字をつけてそれから多い版稽古事って呼ば
れるようになったんですけどものぞく勉強しました
そのとき女子部に入ったときにまあ
あの法律も法律だけどこれから世の中
英語ぐらいはできなくちゃいけないと思って
ess 数がはアンその頃アメリカに生が終え大勢入って門戸を広く広げてたもんです
から
早速引水枚履く入れていただいてもう一丸ごとにいいあの
入り浸って英語を勉強しています
鎌田版ですけどはい
東京行って運動止めるんだったらを歌うなかったらって言って
10日歌いっていうのを中からね声を出す
であの対数の代わりになるで歩いてました柔道どうか歌が聞こえてきたんで他の餅って
10 log 10
柔道場で始まったあの
歌いとか姉妹とかって言う
習ってそれも未だに続いてます
今はそんなことであのやってたんですけど
まああの線損を
ひどかったひどかったですねそれで男の学生は毎日毎日
栗くり坊主になって戦場に出てしまって残っているのは具合の悪い人と
こんなばかりですまあそれも終わってやっと戦争終わったということで
終わったんですよ21年に
学部を卒業したんです少しまた今度就職ですね
さてし無職沿いです昔あった大きなはしてのみの半紙に筆で絵寺駅紹介て何枚かいてが
覚えてません
でも片っ端から日本の会社を受けて歩いたんですでどこ行っても雇ってくれないんです
最後にもうここをことがられた行くとこないんだけどと思ってる
それでそこに座ってましたら
名前覚えたんですよねはいって言ったらなんだお嬢ちゃん買ってし喧嘩も言うんですね
あのうじょうちゃんに悪かったそうしましたら御嬢ちゃんを雇わないのお嬢ちゃんねお
茶くみ菅させられない
それに大学等の月給は払えないっておっしゃるんですよ
そういう理由でね今まで言葉られてたんですか
でも私もうここに入れていたキャピ行くとこがないもんですからどうぞ私の学歴を条
学校で切ってくださいって話しましたそこはいかないってもう
労働組合がどんどんどんどんたいと
してきてるのになことしたらね会社を潰されちゃう
とにかくお嬢ちゃんをやたーはないのっていわけでまあどうしようか者って思ってまし
たら
あるかったら
明治の英語にいたんだってって言ってじゃあもう日本の会社で約なとりあえず雇って
くれないんだったら
あの通訳に試験でも受けてみた後せいか数私が言うがそんなん通用すると思いません
でしたけど
もう
どっかで就職しなきゃなんないと受けましたそれで本当に驚いたんですが買っちゃった
んです
それで今のぼり旗にあるベージ生命の見るそこで雇ってくれました
同じ女の数約一人ですいろんなの通学一人でしたけどもまぁ一人じゃから皆さんが可愛
がってくれて重宝があってくれて
おっいればた
市はあの
その母の敷いたレールに乗ってきのってたおかげかなんか
まあ日本文化というものを少しずすごい数となっています
あの茶道とかかどうとか修二というのは私たちの頃はもう状発行入れば成果にあったん
です
そういうするを足してみましたのでまあその
天から後に養っていただいてからも
何も知らない1人ダブ役に立ってそんなことが付い早く居たちました
でその時士になった人たちの
つい去年おととしまで文通して atis ご家族ダメ帰った時はみんな
止めてくれて2て歩いてくれてみ養ってくれて
もう本当に長い間いにーず何年も私はあの
楽しい思いをさせてもらいました
それでまあ就職はしたんです
そし
それぞれなことしてましてそうしましたがあの縁があって結婚することになったんです
でどうしようかなと思ったんですけどそこのお父さんが弁護士してましてそこの
お父さんが村井に出したんですね
まあいろいろまあ家や奥さんもいるし
息子も娘を招いて色々あると思うけども上げて家に嫁に来てもらえないだろうか
私数値があんなに押しちゃうんだからちょっと考えてみたらってんで考えたのが運の
尽きでした
結婚してみましたら法律からもんですからこれはいい
もう私の友達や先輩があのその
司法試験
っていうのをみんな受ける勉強を始めてましたから私もその手法
法律家の家に嫁に来たらその勉強させてくる
もらえるもんだと思ってでそんな話をしましたら
あと夕日の k 氏が
いき県の紀南にも法律感が入らないのよ
あなたもっと好きなことがあるでしょ他のことやなさいって言うんですねそれでえ
そんなこと言われたってと思ってましたら
その子の命座学の高額を作られた堀口捨巳先生という方と
お知り合いになってそんな学力先生が
あた私があそうそうそのアメリカ軍に勤めている時にあの方点から引き揚げるってき
たり友達がみんな職がなくて職場でてその結婚相手も職がなくてお父さんも食から打っ
て彼女たち何も何かできるって言ったら娘の声をやってたんで4歳ならできる
それから私水
じゃんって言ってそのアメリカのおばさん達の姉スカート伸ばしたり縮めたり
でそんな仕事をもらってそれでうちに仕事は作って彼女に仕事を配って洋服になりまし
た
いう保険も兼業でやってました
でまぁそんなことで結婚してもそれやってたんです
あの
その
弁護士ない他店の停止はちゃんと養ってくれなかったものですから
びっくりしてまた叩かれたんですだったんですよ
そんなことがあってそれで500先生に巡り会ってあの自在の話をしたら
リザ犬本はね建築なのよで試験買ったら入れてあげるからとおっしゃってる
それですこれは私はものづくり好きでしたから
これはいい猛犬月に飛びつこうと思って高額入れてもらいました
女一人でした
でまぁ小泉先生を灯していろんなことして
で運命です同棲あるなぁ日本建築いいもう的今食えてはごめんだと思う
あの
茶室とかいろんなことを勉強してですけども私が住んでます自宅も私のじゃ室もあの
自分の設計なんです
で建築は今も続いています
それで皆様にご提案したいということはもう皆さん
あの海外国際人になるあるになって一生懸命
語学勉強していらっしゃったからきっと皆さんの英語はもう世界中どこ行っても1錠で
通じると思うんです私達の頃とは違って
ですけどもそれだけでは足りないんですね
ですから日本文化んいろいろあります
なんでもいいですから少しでもかじってって言い方は語弊がありますけど
少しのメーカー勉強してそれで外国でた時に外国にすると付き合うときに
あの日アン文化茶道とか言いませんけど作動で言えばその
なんていうのはあのうお茶をたててあの人に飲ませだけじゃないんですね
建物も勉強ですしにはも勉強ですし
そして道具も勉強なんですね出かけ塾をあのかけたりお客さまの前で勝てたり下ろし
たりお花を生けたり
それからをこうも行動なんて難しいところまでいかなくてもそこでお香焚いてみんなで
行
まあシティ
聞くとかそういうあの日本の古い伝統がいっぱい詰まっているんです
ですから
私の息子なんか入らせますと日本文化をちょっと習おうと思ったら
お茶が一番お得ですよ言い方をするんですけどまぁそんなことで
あの
まあできれば遊びでここで皆さんあの
作動になさっている方いらっしゃいますか
あんなところにいらっしゃいましたん
でお抹茶を飲んだことないっていう方いらっしゃいますか
皆さん飲んでらっしゃるじゃあもう文句ないですねねっ
もーちゃんの作り方ちゃ抜けは一つですけども一番先に一番いいとこい
not 波が出るときに覆いをしておいてその一番いい葉っぱを包んでそれをスチーム
して
で乾かしてそれを石臼で挽いてっていうのは抹茶なんですねだから
まぁそれぐらいのことはあの
女3になったら捨てていただきたいと思いますしそれから
桃源をライムを峠って日本だけのもいいんじゃないじゃないっておっしゃるかと思い
ますけどあの茶の道具って実で出来てるものっていうのはみんな陶芸なんですね
私はもうちゃうんからあの
下記から
樫木から全部自分で作って焼いてますですから
を着地どお茶のデッサンたちは皆さんご自分のお茶は思ってそれでお稽古して足単走
それで
まあそれからもう一つみなさんに伺いたいのは
茶の融点はだいたい同じものだっていうことを思っていらっしゃいますか
あの
縁論なの女嘘でもやってますけど元は江戸の負けまでは全部
あの道のつく6の男性のもんだったんですね
それがあの明治の初めにあの
京都博覧会がありましてその時にえ
裏千家の玄々斎提出は学科が来るお客さんにせっちゃんお抹茶を飲む世帯だけど床に
座らせるのは無理だろうからといって
牛令達データ書くあのてないさんもお客さんもみんなおこしかけっていうのをあの考案
して太平氷河も良かったんですって
その後で玄々斎先生つらつら考えてみたら
女子あの人口の半分は女だったこれから女にも教えようと言って女が表立って作動に
携われるようになったのは明治の初めからなんです
ですからあの家は男の生徒さんが女の性とされる数が多いんです
皆さんが枚橋のところに男の人がいるって言うから当たり前なのよーっていうその話を
しますたそんなに女のある日が浅いんだって実はそうしてます
まあそんなことで私は
茶道と限らず何でもよろしいか日本文化をみんなあの身につけてついて海外へどんどん
どんどん発信していただきたいと思うんですね
幻魔あの
まあそんなことです私が皆さんに
お願いしたいことはあのどうぞ
そして日本のカルチャーに少しずつ
あのでもいいからあのちょっといいんです深く行く行くのは後ほど
時間もかかりますしきっと金も買うと思いますけどあの
そんなことはぼちぼちいいんですと博打だけでもしっかりと身につけて
それがあの人に伝わるようなティっていうのがその
え
何年前ですかな私大衆ユーザーの用の7月4日前ですから
75年です前のその明大生のたっての願いです
どうぞ皆さんそんなことで日本文化を少しでも
結構ですか見つけてあのどんどん世界に発信していただきたいと思います
どうも下手な話を長々せご静聴ありがとうございました
よろしくお願い致します